bonjour vous êtes sur Radio nous
retrouvons les brigades du rire bonjour
les brigades du rire
avec Radio pimpon la poussière elle
colle siphon ah bah c'est tant mieux
je
[Musique]
ferai pas installer vous de plus en plus
de monde chez le médecin pour fièvre et
courbatures depuis plusieurs semaines
l'épidémie de grippe explose plus 57% de
consultations en 7 jours et une
augmentation des hospitalisations de
118% selon le dernier rapport de santé
publique France mais en réalité quand on
regarde le taux on est aux environs de
400%.000 donc on est certes au-dessus de
300%.000 la dernière épidémie mais on
est bien en dessous des 600%.000 qu'on
avait atteint par exemple lors du pic de
2018 la genèse de l'histoire est
terrible parce que mon fils se tue en
moto en juillet 90
et je ne suis pas j'ai pas voulu
reconnaître le corps à la morgue ce qui
fait que j'ai toujours eu dans mon
subconscient
comme je l'avais pas vu le fait que
c'était pas lui ça fait 6 heures que
j'attends et on me dit pas ce sera pour
leur prochain et tout une situation
difficile à gérer pour les soignants
oui par exemple on a des projections
aujourd'hui pour un certain nombre
d'hôpitaux du nord de Paris avec une
réduction du lit à l'hôpital
Lariboisière on construit un nouvel
hôpital un tiers des lits de médecine va
disparaître alors même qu'on a passé la
crise covid alors même qu'on a répété
qu'on a besoin de lire alors même
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
fonctionner dans deux ans c'est une
catastrophe totale
est en train de toucher quoi exactement
le médecin m'a dit donc on prend son mal
en patience et puis on attend à mon avis
il faudrait quatre
malades pour un médecin après bon le
système économique veut que ça soit
comme ça on fait avec mais sinon c'est
chiant la Chine décide d'assouplir
encore un peu plus ces restrictions
sanitaires à partir du 8 janvier la
quarantaine imposée aujourd'hui à tous
les voyageurs qui entrent sur le
territoire sera supprimé situation
paradoxale après trois ans d'isolement
total la Chine choisit de s'ouvrir au
monde alors que les quatre covid se
multiplient dans le pays que les
hôpitaux débordent de patients
plus de place dans les chambres
funéraires
les corps sont entreposés
jusque dans des conteneurs
on allait mourir si on ne rouvrait pas
l'économie c'est le plus important
la réouverture s'est faite trop
rapidement beaucoup de gens le pensent
en terme de médicaments d'équipements
nous n'étions pas prêts
de décès
cause officiels de la mort rhume sévère
où sont les experts qui ont décrit le
covid comme un rhume invitons-les à
visiter les crématoriums il comprendront
la situation le moteur il enlève son
casque il a la barbe et moi j'ai cette
espèce de réflexe à la con de le
regarder me dire dans ma tête [ __ ]
mais enlève ta barbe je t'ai reconnu tu
vois et en remontant dans la voiture je
lui dis mais [ __ ] ça c'est une idée ça
je vais me déguiser je vais aller voir
des gens qui me connaissent et au moment
où ils vont péter un câble on enlève le
truc les nouvelles plaques de rue
viennent d'être livrées il y en a près
de 160 que vous avez des noms variés
qu'avec vous pouvez voir Aretha
frankline Adèle des artistes décédés
d'autres biens vivants de Freddie
Mercury à Kurt Cobain en passant par
Zazie ou même Guillaume Aldebert mais il
n'y aura pas de rue Jules à Saint-Jean
torse on voulait que les valeurs de
notre commune ressortent un soin en
corrélation avec les valeurs du chanteur
c'est le cri primal non on le fait pas
ça
c'est un cri de délivrance de joie que
j'ai eu envie de faire que je suis
désolé que c'était pas prévenu que
j'avais crié les habitants consultés ont
pu faire des propositions ils ont déjà
adopté leur nouvel adresse et ben nous
il me semble que c'est Elvis Presley
donc voilà donc c'est sympa aussi nous
c'est rue Charles Aznavour et pour nos
écuries c'est Alicia Keys
je trouve que c'est très simple ça donne
de la gaîté ça donne envie de chanter
c'est vrai mais le cri primal il est là
il faut que tu m'apprennes dans le grave
ça libère ouais
en fait c'est une vibration très très
forte
[Musique]